everybody sorry for the crappy video I'm
making this at my parents house on a
phone as many of you know yesterday was
for the Orthodox was Easter Saturday and
today is paska is Easter and yesterday I
spent most of the day with with my son
and some friends putting sandbags on the
dike of our city our city is near the
water our own house is about 500 meters
from a large lake and the water had been
rising and rising two years ago the
water rose more higher than it had in a
hundred years and this year the water
was rising even more and so as we were
putting sandbags on the dike we could
see that there was only a few inches
before the water came up to the very top
of the dike so last night at about 7:00
I hear now I thought it was a bit later
but around 7:00 one of the dikes broke
and about a seven foot breach and water
started to pour in to the city we heard
a neighbor of ours came to her house and
told us that that I can broke broken and
that people on the street next to us
were being evacuated so we started
scrambling around the house trying to
move things around trying to put things
up higher whatever it is we could do but
then within a few minutes the police and
the firefighters were coming up our
street and were telling everybody that
they had to leave now and as they were
coming up the street they had water
underneath their feet as as they were
coming towards our house and we around
our house of water it was just rising we
could see it rising and so we just had
to to grab a few things
I didn't even grab any clothes my kids
were able to least grab a few clothes
and we got in the car and we left with
water under our wheels our house is
about
about 13 feet lower at the top of the
dike of course the water then never
reached that high every year they
there's a bit of water but it had never
reached that high and so we have no idea
what the situation is
it seems pretty inevitable that at least
the basement of the house will be
totally flooded that's where my office
is that's where my stuff is I was able
to grab a few things and put them on the
top floor but uh I don't know I know
what's gonna happen so so these I don't
know what I'm gonna do in terms of
making videos for you guys I will try to
figure something out
of course the city everything is closed
off I won't be able to get to my house
for a while now to get to see if there's
some stuff that has survived and if some
equipment nets arrive so so at least for
now I don't know what I wouldn't do I
might make the videos on on this phone
or figure something out I have no idea I
have to admit that I am not completely
unaware that this happened on Easter
Saturday on the day that Christ is laid
into the tomb and I know other you guys
who follow me understand the symbolism
of death and the symbolism of the flood
and the symbolism of water and and so
you know I'm not completely unaware of
the the let's say the apropos nature of
the fact that I had been at increasingly
been making videos about upside down
clown world about about death about the
edge about water about all this stuff
I'm making a graphic novel about st.
Christopher and so so I'm not completely
unaware of the symbolism happens moment
right now as I make this video and so
that's it guys that I don't have much to
say I am going to try to figure things
out with my family right now we're at my
parents house and so we at least have a
place to stay and and I will try to keep
you guys
in formed so that you know if there's
art if there aren't the usual amount of
videos coming out at least don't know
why that's happening and so all I can
say is at least for now I ask people to
pray for the city pray for our family
pray for this crazy mess I mean the
water was going up so fast and a few
streets away from us there's a there's a
mobile home park you know and so a
trailer park and there are a lot of Oh
people in that trailer park and a lot of
people who are sick and who are not
doing well
and so I just hope that everybody got
out alive and you know there was there
were so many I've never seen so many so
many police so many so many emergency
vehicles the army was there and as we're
trying to leave the city um anyways so
it's all right guys this is it for me
and and I'll see you soon